all right Mara
Mara uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally I originally grew up
in New Jersey
um I was born in Long Branch New Jersey
I grew up there until I was 18 and then
moved out to Long Island
and then moved to Brooklyn and spent
most of my adult life living in Brooklyn
New York what was your family like
growing up
my parents got divorced when I was very
very young
um
they both remarried
had new families of their own so I was
kind of ping-ponged back and forth
for the most part so how would you
describe your childhood in general
um very nurturing for my father
um
my mother never told me she loved me
never hugged me married
a
sociopath in my opinion were completely
estranged we haven't spoken in over 20
years
just ice cold
and after you were done to school did
you graduated high school I did graduate
high school and I have associates degree
so I do yeah what'd you do with your
life
um do you work I I did I I got pregnant
very young I worked I was a bookkeeper
um
I've worked in dispensaries down here in
Florida
bookkeeping and administrative assistant
was most of my jobs for throughout my
life when I wasn't in active addiction
so
so you're you're an addict as well
absolutely yes I was I am you still are
yes I'm recovering yeah yes but I am and
I'm an addict on journeying
towards a better to better myself and
raise my level of consciousness
yeah
and you had a husband who
was in the same walking the same path
yes so I had met my husband Chris
um
God we were so young I was 18 he was 19.
he was a few years older than me
um we got married I got we got pregnant
had a baby at 20 big wedding the next
year had her whole life ahead of us
we met in an at an n a meeting actually
and um
he ended up in a car accident like it
and took over
it just was 15 years of turmoil
and he ended up uh passing away
from a heroin overdose November 7th uh
in the year of 2000.
so my son was two when I was 22.
and then
from there your story gets even more
interesting because your son followed in
Dad's footsteps
so my son
um
his name is Carter
he is forever 22.
um he had nine months sober
from long-term treatment
and he
got out
and one day he was
he walked in on his roommate smoking
crack
his counselor told him to leave so he
left
he was waiting to get into another Sober
House and in the meantime on September
7th 6 2001
he took what he thought was an oxycontin
that ended up being pure fentanyl
car Fentanyl and methamphetamine
and he was pronounced dead at 12 43 A.M
and he passed 20 years to the day that
my husband passed away
I'm sorry
in your life now
is centered around what
my life now
um is centered
at first it was centered around
wanting to die
after losing my life is now defined
before and after
it's before Carter and after Carter
and um
so in the beginning it was a lot of
just these ups and downs and shock and I
mean I'm still in shock at 16 months and
um I started advocating to a lot of
advocating mailing out Narcan for free
um when I got to the place where I was
healthy to do so
um
I'm going to school to become an
addiction coach with psychedelic
integration
I know from my experience
not only with my addiction and my grief
and how much psychedelics have helped me
to heal
I know that the possibilities are
endless
I've just
restored my face I started praying every
morning and every night to God and my
guardian angel in the beginning I was
praying for God to take me in my sleep
I didn't want to wake up I just wanted
to be with Carter
and the suicidal ideations like
it it's like a ping pong ball at the
Olympics
going back and forth inside your brain
like okay well
I can Google professional or whatever
it's called and get it mailed here and
just give myself a hot shot and be done
and be at peace
but then I have to tell myself
down Carter loses his voice
I'm Carter's voice I'm Carter's voice
so I need to be healthy and healed
so I can move forward in my journey
to not only spread awareness and
advocate so no other family has to
enter this
every eight minutes something is dying
from Fentanyl
and it's flooding there I mean xylazine
is in the picture now I mean it's just
it's out of control narcanism work on
that I mean it's us parents
that are fighting a fight that our
government should be fighting
and we're grieving and we're still
having to fight this fight
when we do so but I hope we there's a
rally every year in DC that we all go to
um we put up billboards
we hold rallies in our own towns we
write letters I mean I send a letter
every week to the New York State
Governor and the New York State mayor
every single week the same letter
I know I'll never hear back I don't give
a [__]
her son died from fentanyl
poisoning when he was 17 her nephew I'm
sorry her nephew died and she refused to
put together a 12-person panel to help
study the fentanyl
xylazine influx in New York state she
decided that New York State needed a new
stadium and there wasn't enough funding
what the [__]
I mean
I just I just it blows my mind so
I had the spiritual awakening and I
started
you know
when you kind of come out of your grief
a little bit and you start to have these
through psychedelics I've been able to
do this find this connection with Carter
and myself and the universe and God and
realize we are all one
um
I'm realizing you know I'm picking up my
on empathic abilities
um
Carter I get signs from Carter all the
time now
um
I mean my room number when I checked in
here is 111. it's just you know I I had
this spiritual awakening and
a random not random podcast uh I'm sorry
YouTube video came up on my feed is it
was called is the devil real
and I've always believed in the devil
and demons obviously
but I've always struggled with my
relationship with God and you know I was
like why isn't God answering my prayers
well Maura you're asking him to kill you
in your sleep that's almost somehow God
works and everyone doesn't understand
different understanding of God this is
just my understanding of God
and
um so it was just an interview with a
priest an exorcist and he said you know
everybody on the universe every morning
and every night
quick prayer to God in your garden angel
thank you for this morning it will live
by your will not mine blah blah blah
acknowledge your guardian angel
so that night I did it
and then I did it the next morning and
then the next night and like I felt a
shift like a sense of peace
and then a week later I went to this
music festival
and took a combination of psychedelics
and I just was able to absorb all of the
love and energy of the music and the
lyrics
and just be in the moment and
I realized Carter is always with me he's
here
and my job is to
let go of my guilt
advocate
finish school
and I I found my purpose my purpose is
to help other people heal and grow
and learn and continue and move forward
in their Journey
so as shitty as my
as the cards that were dealt to me are
I wouldn't take back anything
I mean [__]
I would not take back one single [__]
thing I ever did not one trip to Philly
not one needle stuck in my arm not one
[__] thing because if I didn't do any
of that I would not be right here where
I am right now
and we're so conditioned from birth
to use these words such as never can't
won't
you know
and trust me it's a process I've worked
very very hard on myself through
meditation breath work
ketamine infusion therapy
um psilocalvin
I mean I've been able to get off of nine
psychiatric medications I'm only on two
now
and this has been going on I'm 44 years
old and this has been going on since I
was around 20. so what psychedelics have
you used
so um MDMA
ketamine
psilocybin DMT
Ayahuasca
um
bufo which is called the toad
and that's about it but I do I mean I
micro dose every day with cell salmon
are there certain ones that are more
effective than others oh absolutely
every psychedelic is used for a
different purpose so ketamine for
example
actually repairs your neurotransmitters
in your brain
um so MDMA is a heart opening uh
psychedelic so
if you're struggling with intimacy
issues or you know relationship issues
even within yourself I'm not talking
boyfriend girlfriend just anybody
um you know that would be more geared
towards that ketamine is a
disassociative drug
whereas so you're like just out there
and your expansion of the universe
Ayahuasca is a very very heavy plant
medicine
that is
like you need a very
heavy heavy prep for that it's a lot of
purging
um however
that is the one experience that
absolutely began my healing Journey was
doing my the Ayahuasca Journey
and since then and still at Solomon is
really used
um I mean people microdose every day
just to keep you elevated it just
elevates you just keeps you elevated and
if you were to eat you know
half a three 3.5 grams you would go on a
magic mushroom trip and that's just more
about kind of fun and enjoying yourself
and vibing out to music so all
psychedelics are geared towards certain
things
so I want to make that very clear like
they're not something to be mixed with
and played with I mean they're
medicinally used and for me
as an advocate what kind of things have
you learned or what kind of things are
you
sharing and teaching
because you know this fentanyl is a new
a new thing oh my God so I mean you know
you know you have so many varying
opinions you know some people believe in
harm reduction some people don't I'm a
big believer in harm reduction there
should be Narcan in vending machines as
a matter of fact just yesterday a bill
was passed and Narcan is now going to be
available in vending machines and
over-the-counter and
available everywhere for everyone to
have so that is huge and people want to
call these safe injection sites they're
not safe injection sites they're
overdose prevention centers so in my
mind
you know
the first step is keeping the person
who's using alive that's what we that's
the main goal is to keep them living so
if they have a safe place to go and use
drugs where there's registered nurses
with Narcan whatever the drug is if
they're shooting meth or they're
shooting heroin or they're taking pills
they have a safe place to go it's
medically supervised
so you know I'm a big believer in harm
reduction some people aren't
um
and billboards graphics
you know I'm very active on Tick Tock
making a lot of videos just promoting
Fentanyl and the dangers
I mean you cannot
you were literally putting a bullet in a
barrel
spinning the barrel pulling the trigger
when you take anything off the street
including marijuana kids are dropping
dead from Vape carts weed it's not just
cocaine and meth and the hard [__] it's
everywhere it's [__] everywhere and
it's literally two greens that fit on
the tip of a pencil point that is how
much can kill you
so why is it that drugs are such a huge
problem now
we live in a society that is ignorant to
people suffering
um I believe that you know addiction and
you know we live our society is
crumbling humanity is at its worst we've
we're at our the worst we've ever been I
mean people use drugs and I think people
continue to use drugs to escape they
escape childhood trauma uh adult trauma
pain depression physical pain and once
you're in it you're in it
so
you know we live in a culture that's
very accepting of and stigmatizes you
know the junky drug addict when you know
no these are sick people that need help
and they need to be approached
approached with Grace Grace and
compassion and love
until they're ready for treatment of or
not
so that is the main reason why I'm going
to school to become addiction coach
because it's not pushing rehabs and
detoxes if you're still using you can
still come to me and I will just coach
you through it on your different options
and availability so I blame it I mean
our society just puts a stigma on I mean
not only addiction grief
anything that is the unspoken I mean
so and I'm breaking that stigma by being
here
as are you
yeah I think it takes something like
what happened to your son and your
husband
to get you off your ass to
be motivated to do something to share
this information one thousand percent
before more before this
I thought I was on a journey I had no
[__] idea
the level of Consciousness that I have
come to raise just Within Myself and my
ability to listen to my body and know
what I need when I need it in order to
heal and to prioritize you know yes I
had school today but this was a priority
to get the message out and to heal
so you know
just it's one day at a time one second
at a time
whether you're actively using grieving
whatever it is it's
life is hard like we live in a harsh
cruel ugly mean world
and
there's just no more kindness left there
are very few I'm not going to say no
more that's you know these forever
terminologies never can't won't
you know removed removed from my
vocabulary or trying to
but
you know I mean the fact that I didn't
pick up
after losing my son
that to me is a true miracle that was my
next question
never crossed my mind really not once
I'd put a bullet in my head before I'd
pick up another jog or a drink well I
don't drink but I would put a bullet in
my head using never even use them as not
crossed my mind I would have to sit at
least seven years
and it was not an option I would kill
myself before I took another truck what
helped you quit
um methadone
unfortunately and then you wean off that
yes which onto Suboxone
um
uh but are you using anything Suboxone
so I'm currently on Suboxone still yes
yes so I am on Suboxone
um
but being on the methadone I was at 30
milligrams stuck at 30 milligrams for
like eight for like four years
so
I finally made the decision in February
I said you know what this is just
clouding my mind and I made this
decision switch to the Suboxone
and it's like my head cleared out I'm
like yawning again all these changes in
my body while I'm going through my grief
yes it's uncomfortable but I know that I
have the tools and the strength and the
faith but you know to get me through are
you planning on on tapering off of
Suboxone absolutely yeah I know this is
within a year
I'm gonna be off of completely and clean
absolutely yeah I don't want to be
I mean being on methadone for so long
it's like it was it's liquid handcuffs I
mean and it is I mean methadone was
created by Hitler as a weapon of mass
destruction not many people know that
um and you know these methadone clinics
yes
it saved my life
however
I feel like they're very poorly
regulated
and they push you to keep going up on
your methadone because it's a it's all
about money I mean let's face it the
world runs on money so
you know it just I came to a point for
me where I said I'm done enough is
enough I was terrified to make that
transition
withdrawals
terrified but I was in such a better
place and I had the support and to be
honest I slept right through it I don't
remember anything
and now I'm feel amazing clear-headed
more focused
more just ability to connect with Carter
the universe God my guardian angel
just being at one with spirit I mean
it's just been
really since I mean I hit that year one
year mark in November and everyone said
the second year is the hardest
and I kept saying and everyone kept
saying like drilling that into my head
so I like had that like oh my God how in
the [__] is the second year the harder
than the first year oh my good God
somebody kill me
and I kept saying in the back of my mind
it's not going to be for me because I'm
going to make it different
and that's what I did
uh you know it's gonna come again
the tsunami is Gonna Come that's grief
but
you know what now that I have faith and
I trust in the universe and I trust in
my own ability and My Own Strength
and I know that there's hope there for
all of us
because we are all one
so it's just about spreading love and
being kind
and what you put out there is what you
get back so
I think you and I are passing you know
kind of doing the same thing just in
different
ways I'm I'm more focused on
what causes these problems and maybe
what we can do to prevent that and
you're focused more on the front lines
of what's Happening absolutely right on
the street yes
that's what I was so drawn I mean I've
been following you guys forever and I've
just like I came to a point during my
grief Journey where I was like I have to
submit the story
because it's so unique
compared to most fentanyl poisonings
yeah in general so to say what advice
would you give to somebody who's got a
family member or is is going through
this themselves
my advice
make sure that you have Narcan on you at
all times
this is four milligrams
four milligrams if somebody is overdosed
being poisoned by Fentanyl
so you'll start to foam at the mouth
um your eyes will roll back they'll
start to turn blue just like any other
overdose
just give them the Narcan I could squirt
it up my nose right now and it would
have no effect so it's not going to kill
you
it's not going to do any harm
um
and like I said they just passed the law
and even if it hasn't been passed in
your state you can go and get it through
your Pharmacy you may have to pay for it
but any family member who has an active
addict
whether their drug of choice is cocaine
marijuana I don't it doesn't give a it
doesn't [__] matter because fentanyl
is in everything and this will literally
give that person enough time until the
paramedics get there Narcan is like a
shot of adrenaline so Narcan is
naltrexon so which reverses the
um effects of a opioid poisoning of an
opioid overdose so it can be used on
heroin fentanyl however it does not work
on xylazine
so with xylazine in the drug Supply Now
what is xylazine xylazine is a horse
tranquilizer
that is now being put in the drug Supply
is that the stuff you see like in
Kensington yep Kensington Philly yep
absolutely the zombie drug yeah drink
yep I don't think it's made it to
California yeah no I it's really it's
really bad up in um Manhattan like
Northeast area real Kensington it's like
oh it's
it's everywhere
um I used to cop in Philly like way back
in the day and it's just like looking at
it now it's like oh my God like but
so now that xylazine is in the drug
Supply Narcan does not work on xylazine
so that's a [__] problem and the
fentanyl test strips are [__]
because
you have to scrape off a tiny bit of
amount of the pill or whatever substance
but it's called the chocolate chip
cookie effect if you look at a chocolate
chip cookie
the part that you scraped off May test
negative for fentanyl but there could be
two grains worth of salt in fentanyl in
any other part of the pill so that part
of harm reduction is complete [__]
but everybody should be carrying Narcan
using not using family member not family
everybody on in America should be
carrying Narcan
I've used I had to use it on somebody in
a parking lot
till the paramedics came so
I mean it's just it's [__] everywhere
and it's you know grieving going to
school trying to Advocate Advocate and
you know while the government you know
sits back
meanwhile biting could put I'm not
blaming Biden Obama Trump Biden they're
going back hundreds of years they're all
[__] complicit they're all [__]
complicit you know what any one of them
at any time could put an executive order
to declare the terrorists
um where do you think the fentanyl is
coming from oh the so the fentanyl is
coming from Mexico the precursor
chemicals to make the fentanyl are
coming from China
but now
Mexico is figuring out how to make the
precursors themselves so they're less
they're leaning Less on China it's also
coming from Canada
so this whole closed the southern border
border yes you know we have to man The
Southern border but we would have to
build a wall around the entire [__]
continent and stop the mail flow if you
ever wanted to stop the flow drugs into
our country
so [__] unrealistic like declare the
cartels a terror terrorist organization
so that will allow American troops to go
in and blast down these like labs in the
[__] jungle that they're making
fentanyl for five cents
you know and shipping thousands and
hundreds and thousands of pills and
whatever right up San Diego and Arizona
and you know it's just and then you know
declare weapon fentanyl weapon of mass
destruction then the people who are
dealing it and selling it and someone
dies get harsher penalties like these
are steps that the government can take
and they don't
I have no control over the government
none of us do so like I have to let that
[__] go
and that's why us us parents have to
fight this fight
and it's [__] [__]
but we do it because there are angels
and we don't just do it for our angels
we do it for
everybody's angels and to prevent
anybody from having to go through this
it's not just for us it's for everybody
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned from all of this
wow what's the most important lesson
I've learned
that if you are not okay and if you
can't take care of you first you are
incapable of being there for anybody
else
self-care is absolute priority when it
comes to life in general
grief addiction
whatever
if you are not okay spiritually mentally
and I don't mean like you don't be
perfect you don't feel grounded
you know you need to be grounded and
just trust and fit and you know
you know that's what's helped me to be
grounded and just have faith and Hope
and just checking I just keep tracking I
just keep putting one foot in front of
the other it's what I have to do
so
yeah all right Mara thank you so much
for sharing your story thank you so much
for having me Mark very interesting talk
yes yes appreciate you thank you very
much yeah